je suis pour la vaccination et je suis
pas pour la vaccination parce que je
suis médecin et c'est pas utile d'être
médecin pour se rendre compte que les
gens qui aujourd'hui sont à l'hôpital
aujourd'hui son temps réel sont des gens
qui n'ont pas été vaccinés pas forcément
volontairement d'ailleurs parce que ya
pas eu de assez de vaccins dans tel ou
tel territoire le deuxième élément c'est
le pass le pass le problème c'est qu'ils
impasse c'est normal qu'ils impasse pour
aller voyager en avion on entendait des
grandes manifestations
mais le président de la république avait
pris l'engagement que cela ne toucherait
pas la vie quotidienne quand tout à
l'heure j'entendais sur votre radio
en terrasse il faut dans ma ville dans
toutes les villes de france
faire un contrôle par le commerçant lui
même par le restaurateur
de dd passoni terre en terrasse c'est
une situation qui crée des tensions qui
créent des violences vous espérez
l'asservissement pour les terrasses
heures non l'horizon de la logique
médicale c'est que à l'air libre on le
sait depuis longtemps la propagation du
virus est beaucoup moindre donc on n'a
pas des positions qui sont des positions
calqué sur le sanitaire on a des
positions qui sont calqués sur la
politique on a eu droit à des couvre
feux à 18 heures et puis surtout je veux
dire ce gouvernement a dit une chose et
son contraire et donc il a perdu de la
crédibilité est maintenant quand il
propose une solution qui peut paraître
qui est en grande partie logique bien il
n'est plus crue nous avons une prise de
conscience d'abord que on peut gagner
cette élection présidentielle pour faire
une autre politique
et puis le deuxième élément c'est que
probablement on ne nous pardonnera pas
nos militants ceux qui pensent comme dos
ceux qui pensent qu'il faut à la fois
lié de l'humanité de l'autorité dans la
gestion publique la clarté aussi ceux
qui pensent que le territoire quelque
chose d'important bien ces gens là ne
nous pardonneront pas de perdre à cause
de division et nous pardonneront de
perdre sur nos idées et nos pères nos
peurs pardonneront pas de perdre sur nos
divisions et noé et noé nos égoïsmes